sometimes even the most talented horror
actors choose to hang up their hats and
leave the industry eventually
no matter how much they loved making
their movies working in hollywood for
any period of time can be enough to burn
anybody out john franklin rose to
prominence in the horror world when he
starred as
isaac the creepy young cult preacher in
1984's children of the corn
he went on to land a small role in
1988's child's play and
later played cousin it in the adams
family and adam's family values
he could have easily continued acting
but the unexpected loss of two loved
ones caused him to question whether or
not he
really wanted to keep working in showbiz
and after the events of september 11th
2001 he realized that he needed to take
his life in a new direction
so he looked in the mirror and asked
himself what his legacy was
i've entertained you know millions of
years but is that
all that i want written on my tombstone
or my obituary
franklin decided that he needed to take
a break and shortly after this
realization he responded to an
ad for a teaching job he spent over a
decade in the classroom which allowed
him to combine his various passions by
teaching english
and screenwriting among other subjects
today franklin is slowly returning to
acting by taking on parts as he sees fit
though he isn't pursuing those roles
full time
farouza bach gave an eerily convincing
performance as the powerful and
vengeful young witch nancy in 1996's the
craft
as she starred alongside fellow witches
nev campbell robin tunney and rachel
true
the movie is beloved as a cult favorite
and it seemed like bulk could have had a
bright future in horror films but she
never quite fulfilled that promise
looking back she says she simply wasn't
interested in chasing fame
in 2013 she told dread central i never
just want to work for the sake of
working
there has to be something there for me
so that i can grow from the experience
i've never just taken a job because i
wanted the check i struggled a lot with
being pushed too hard in my 20s with
people telling me that i had to keep
taking more and more movies because
that's really only when i'd be relevant
like one of my favorite movies ever is
the craft but i'm sure you get that all
the time
of course but i know we're far removed
from that with no desire to be the
flavor of the moment
bach has instead focused on finding
roles that she can truly feel passionate
about
adrian king is best known for playing
alice hardy in the original friday the
13th
but off screen she had a horrifying
experience that pushed her out of the
public eye for years
she had no idea that shortly after
rising to fame she would be forced to
deal with a real situation that was far
scarier than anything in her movie
career for a year and a half she was
followed by a stalker who pursued her
for a bizarre reason
as he claimed that king reminded him of
someone who had wronged him in the past
unfortunately the authorities initially
dismissed king's claims
she stated that the police even
attempted to place the blame on her for
acting in such a scary movie
king later met with the makers of friday
the 13th part 2 and arranged for her
character to be killed off
as she told uproxx in 2015 i couldn't
handle doing another film and dealing
with what no one else seemed to want to
deal with
it was worse because we didn't know who
the stalker was and it was drawn out and
this person was so brilliant
it really kind of spun me into a very
weird place
king eventually pivoted to voice over
work so that she could keep acting
without appearing on screen
she now primarily works as a winemaker
and artist
michael myers the infamous masked
murderer of the halloween franchise
is one of the most famous villains in
horror movie history
he was played by nick castle in the 1978
original
although you probably wouldn't recognize
him behind the mask you also won't
notice him credited as an actor in many
other movies although he did return for
the 2018 reboot
and he signed on for its sequels while
he walked into a fantastic opportunity
when he was offered the role of michael
myers he never
intended to become an actor in fact he
always dreamed of writing and directing
his own films
so how did castle end up with this
iconic role despite his lack of interest
in acting
as it turns out he and halloween
director john carpenter were close
friends in film school
and after carpenter achieved some early
success he knew that he could help give
castle a career boost so the two of them
teamed up for halloween and castle got
to learn the ropes from a pro
s castle later told dread central the
reason i was doing it was just to hang
out on the set to learn how to become a
director
so it was a great experience for me and
you never know how things are going to
turn out
linda blair was a relative unknown with
little experience under her belt when
she landed the iconic role of regan
mcneil in 1973's the exorcist
her performance as a disturbed child
possessed by a demon is enough to make
anyone's skin crawl thanks to
unforgettable moments that involved head
spinning and split pea soup
blair appeared poised to use that
experience as a stepping stone to a long
and vibrant career but these days she
has a new set of priorities as she
dedicates most of her time to animal
rights activism
she became a vegetarian in 1988 and in
2001 she adopted
a fully vegan diet she's rescued many
stray dogs and she says that she feels a
kinship with these misunderstood animals
because of the way the media portrayed
her after the exorcist came out
in 2013 she told the sydney morning
herald
i realize these dogs are being portrayed
the same as i was
as a monster there was prejudice
misunderstanding and it was
being lied about so i became quite a
forceful speaker on their behalf
blair laments the fact that most
journalists only want to talk to her
about the exorcist rather than her
animal welfare work
as she put it i'm sad but i'm not mad at
them
that movie changed your life completely
but it gave you a megaphone
you didn't realize that for a while but
it gave you a megaphone
to to get your point across when he was
just eight years old david dorfman
starred as aiden in 2002's the ring
he captivated audiences with his
portrayal of a young boy with psychic
abilities whose family is tormented by a
ghostly entity
bent on revenge for the suffering she
endured in her life he also made an
appearance in the 2003 reboot of the
texas chainsaw massacre
while he certainly had the potential to
be a successful adult actor he hasn't
appeared in a film since 2010
ultimately he decided to take a
different path in life fortunately for
his sake it turns out that dorfman's
talents extend beyond acting
a brilliant student he was admitted to
harvard law school at an age when most
people were just starting their
bachelor's degrees
he managed to graduate at the top of his
class when he was only 21 and then
started building his legal career
in 2017 he told refinery29
i've been working as an attorney at
capitol hill in dc and then at one of
the top firms in hong kong i was really
fortunate to be at the justice
department in washington too
honestly i just feel so lucky to have
such interesting experiences
from hollywood to harvard i'm just
really incredibly grateful
for all these great opportunities you
might know devay chase from your
nightmares
she probably popped up there a few times
after she played the vengeful ghost
samara in the ring
the creepy image of a young girl with
black hair hanging in front of her face
could easily
haunt anyone for days not to mention she
made an entire generation dread picking
up the phone whenever it rings
chase didn't land too many other parts
following the ring but she definitely
stayed busy
she voiced lilo in the disney movie lilo
and stitch as well as the tv show based
on it and she also had a recurring part
on the hbo series big love
but recent legal troubles have left her
with an empty acting schedule for the
past few years
in november 2017 she was arrested when
she was caught driving a stolen car
then in 2018 she was arrested again this
time for possession of illegal drugs
whether or not chase chooses to return
to acting we hope she'll be able to get
back on her feet again and stay out of
trouble
if you're a horror hound you surely
remember heather langenkamp as nancy
thompson in the classic 1984 slasher
flick a nightmare on elm street
she started multiple films in the
durable franchise and she's always
spoken highly of the experience
to this day she insists she has no idea
why she was chosen for the role but she
still
feels honored and blessed that she had
the opportunity that was
nancy wes it's not me yeah but it was
you that gave nancy her strength
in 2018 langenkamp lost her teenage son
to brain cancer which prompted her to
take a step back from acting
in 2019 she told pop horror that's why i
haven't really been doing very much for
the last year
because i have been just recovering from
seven years of just real
real horror now that i've kind of moved
beyond that stage of my life i just
really appreciate
being alive and appreciating every gift
that i've been given
langenkamp still loves acting but these
days she's more interested in working on
short films
instead of features she also runs a
makeup effects company with her husband
in 1999's the blair witch project
heather donahue played a film student
who was downright obsessed with
capturing footage of the mysterious
title character
and who refused to turn off the camera
no matter what danger she encountered
the actress never expected that this
little low-budget found footage flick
would make the impact that it has
although the blair witch project drew in
large audiences and caused quite a stir
with its incredibly effective marketing
campaign
donahue's performance wasn't positively
received by everyone
in fact she even won a worst actress
award from the razzies
donahue has said that once the hubbub
over the blair witch project died down
she had a quote
firm lack of interest in appearing in
anything else despite
all the criticism she faced she didn't
give up on acting right away but she
eventually took her career in a
completely different direction when she
decided to begin growing medical
marijuana
she even wrote a memoir called grow girl
about her experiences with the drug
it became really obvious to me why we
have this
long intricate and sometimes dangerous
relationship with this plant
it's hard to believe that danny lloyd
had never acted before he played danny
torrence in 1980s the shining
his performance was so convincing that
it's easy to believe that he actually
had psychic powers
you may have wondered why he didn't go
on to appear in other films after
starring in such an iconic movie
despite his abundant talent he struggled
to land similar opportunities
he continued going on auditions but
aside from securing a role in a
made-for-tv movie about the watergate
scandal
he wasn't offered any parts that he was
interested in although he enjoyed acting
he eventually realized it was time to
leave the industry behind
in 2017 he told the guardian i'm quite
happy with how things went
really i feel like i pretty much hit the
lottery with the shining
i don't regret trying acting when i
decided to stop i don't regret that
either
lloyd grew up to work as a teacher one
who wisely tried to keep his previous
acting experience a secret from his
students to avoid classroom disruptions
however he did get back in front of the
camera one more time to make a cameo in
dr sleep
the 2019 sequel to the shining
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one